the future of the shoppers at a market
in Tripoli is being discussed thousands
of kilometers away in Europe the foreign
ministers are trying to work out how to
secure a shaky truce that's been in
place in Libya since earlier this month
I want to stress once again the fact
that we are not distilling a ceasefire
hmm we are in a truce which is unstable
and you know the truth can be violated
several times a day on some day in
Berlin
world leaders committed to stop
interfering in Libya's Civil War and to
uphold a weapons embargo that's been in
place since 2011 but the talks failed to
deliver serious dialogue between the
warring parties warlord Khalifa Haftar
and the UN recognized administration in
Tripoli I'm a quill - and now I'll have
come to realize that there is no
military solution to the crisis in Libya
despite the fact that huffner and his
forces do not believe in diplomacy nor a
political process we hope that half
stars allies and supporters have also
come to this conclusion and would
recalculate their moves in order to
revive this political process half does
been battling to take over the capital
since April and fighting has killed
close to 300 civilians and displaced
hundreds of thousands more but this
civil war is also a proxy conflict each
side has several powerful international
backers analysts say Europe is trying to
prove its still relevant and United
European ambassadors have been given
four weeks to present concrete proposals
on how to implement the UN arms embargo
which has been repeatedly violated by
both sides
tomber in a way Libya is a kind of
cancer a kind of tumor which is growing
throughout the region it's spreading
despite the diplomatic efforts Kalifa
half does forces continue to blockade
oil ports in the east
cutting output to almost zero oil is
central to Libya's economy its largest
export and a financial lifeline for the
government and Tripoli
oil itself is actually vital in terms of
supplies the power stations hospital and
other key facilities that Libyan
citizens use daily so I expect also
deterioration and humanitarian terms in
Libya in addition to what we've seen
throughout the 10 months of grueling war
the UN is inviting top generals from the
two sides to Geneva next week and yet
another effort to end the unrest Alexei
O'Brien al Jazeera